and thank you for joining us for this
opportunity to engage with our experts
under ethics and innovative
neurotechnologies is my pleasure to
introduce our panel of experts who'll be
available to answer your questions
during this live Q&A session our experts
are dr. Saskia Hendricks dr. Natarajan
dr. Ashley fine singer dr. Francis Shen
and dr. James Mapp for more information
about our experts please refer to the
speaker biographies in the center of
your screen my name is dr. Russian Akash
immune and I will be your moderator for
today's Q&A session bobrucz is delighted
to bring you this incredible opportunity
we would also like to extend our special
thanks to the brain initiative program
directors in particular dr. James mad
for their efforts in organizing today's
session the session is interactive can
lead to an inappropriate motivation to
participate in trials and incomplete
understanding of the goals and risks of
a clinical trial what is the true
importance to know goals and risks great
so the importance is extremely high you
know so in any kind of human research
whether it's a therapeutic clinical
trial or any other trial where you're
conducting neuro scientific studies
informed consent is a cornerstone of
participation and inform consent does
clearly state that risks absolutely need
to be communicated to the IRB initially
and then to participants and I think for
patients to be able to make an informed
decision about the risks and benefits
they need to understand what the goals
of the study are they need to understand
whether there is potentially benefit to
them individually to the group that they
belong to or to society
in general and allow them to make that
risk-benefit judgment that in addition
to it being important for informed
consent it's also important just for
maximizing beneficence to participate
participants in minimizing harm so that
is something that we care about almost
independently have been fun consent as
well the question was what if an
investigator leaves a clinical trial to
go to another institution and what about
the who would if it so the first answer
the answer to the first part of that
question is often the project a clinical
trial would move with the investigator
and we would assure the resources and
the new institution were adequate for
supporting that project in some cases
actually a project might be left behind
and other Co investigators would take
over the management at the local site
but if the expertise or the resources
were inadequate at the at the site being
left behind we would not continue a
project under those conditions the the
responsibility for the care of those
patients remains with the primary
investigator and the institution at
which the original award was made so it
would it would not be acceptable that
the responsibility over those patients
were to just be caught so doctor said is
that their real danger in regulating
ourselves to the extent of entrenching
in our biology in particular in light of
the fact that it's so dynamic in their
20 degrees of freedom
that's a if I understand the question
and I think it's a good one
the concern is that introducing a
neuroscience perspective say in the area
of criminal law might be problematic
because some combination of neuroscience
genetics environment might lead one to
think that all we are is our biology and
the rest doesn't matter I think that's a
concern but one that can be overcome
with proper framing and dialogue in fact
I think brain research here at NIH and
elsewhere makes clear that the brain is
intimately connected with its
environment upbringing social engagement
frame with the rest of the body they
might grow by on everything but in our
body you name it so I think actually in
some ways a biological perspective on
the human condition and Kuban agency
opens up a number of possibilities and
sort of really emphasizes the need for
interventions in a lot of different ways
and so I see the concern but I think it
can be it can be overcome I will note
that historically maybe the questioner
is thinking about this there are
historical examples where that more
nuanced and integrated understanding of
brain in relationship to the rest of
world hasn't been adopted and
over-simplistic over simplistic models
have done some real harm in policy so
it's it's a good thing to be thinking
about but I do think we can overcome it
thank you and we have another one for
you
as individuals approaches to science and
medicine Barry is it especially
challenging to reach consensus on
courtroom and legislative issues in
regard to neural law and are some
individuals at a disadvantage depending
on where they reside they answer the
first part absolutely neuroscience and
law as one judge describes them are
strange bedfellows scientists and
lawyers don't think the same way the
structures are different I talked about
this in the top so there's a lot of
opportunity for disagreement and it is
unclear sometimes what world we want so
hypothetical I often ask my students is
would you want a jury of 12 of the most
highly trained neuroscientist with that
excite you or with that concern you and
and why and I think it raises deep
questions and this gets to the second
part of that question about a sort of
depending on where you live and
differences in culture and politics and
representative democracy there is often
a move in science to think that once
science has discovered something it's a
universal principle and everybody should
just get on board because it's been peer
reviewed and the highest journals and
yet in you know many governance
structures we don't privilege we
acknowledge that we don't necessarily
privilege that scientific information
including neurosciences so I think it's
an open question actually but their
daughters to how different countries and
different states and different
communities and really different
international organizations will choose
to adopt or respond or reject some of
these neuroscience findings thank you
dr. Hendrix are there eight parameters
for participants in neural device
research studies so that's a hard
question to answer
overall so I'm not gonna attempt to do
that I think the way we think about it
is that there might be certain groups of
potential but this offense move and are
more vulnerable and actor require
additional protections and maybe in some
cases and extreme cases we want to
exclude them from research altogether
although that also has drawbacks as I
mentioned in my talk so I think
definitely children are one of them
those most vulnerable groups but I
wouldn't say that there is there
wouldn't be any case that I could think
of in which it would be worthwhile to
include children because maybe the
benefits of including children in
principle could be enough to outweigh
for example a minimal risk study and
there's another question do you believe
there should be established frameworks
governing participants access to a
neural devices post well yes I think it
would be very helpful to have
established frameworks but not because
guidance right now is feeding limited
especially in the realm of devices and I
would say that a secondary
is howdy doubt you that Titans be
because I think we want we want some
sort of guidance that is still
responsive to the fact that we wanted
there's different contextual issues that
matter and that may matter a lot
ethically and for example participants
vulnerability how much they are
benefiting from a device so we we would
want to framework yes but it would still
have to allow for flexibility to respond
to the context or the context your cases
doctor show you have a thought on that
as well no I just said this is it's
tremendously important issue and the law
the regulatory law gets heavily involved
and and it's very complicated these
devices could be with you for a very
long time in ways that pharmacological
interventions are yes it's it's
especially complex because there are
devices that are from established
corporate entities that have a clear
future but the in this space there's
also a lot of startup companies and new
device designs and it's not a simple
framework to design when you're talking
about a company that may not exist in
the future even though a therapy may be
may be beneficial for a patient a
company can still go under for many
reasons so it we have to think about
this in many dimensions y'all go after
you please yeah I was just gonna add
just from a kind of robust ethical
standpoint to I mean these are devices
that are now in someone's body right so
if they're implanted right and so we do
have limits on you know removing them
without consent so you can have
participants who may have benefited from
the trial that's therapeutic trial and
do not want the devices to be taken out
and that's a real problem
can we force them to take it out right
let's question that's a very very
question actually because also in cases
where you you know as well as I do that
in Parkinson's patients where you have
these psychic side effects and so
there's let's a gentleman that comes in
and he has his surgery and now he's
moved into this great functional state
and the Parkinson's has been
therapeutically alleviated but he's got
the gambling and the hypersexuality and
the wife comes and says you know that's
great that he's feeling better take it
out and then you start to come into
these ethical dilemmas or in the case
where there's a side effect where let's
say the patient might become aggressive
and so you know of course everybody
thinks it's a good idea to turn this off
or take it out but the patient doesn't
want to and this would actually speak
very much to you doctor Shanna how can
you legally force a person to have brain
surgery and if you then decide to turn
it and this is actually a real case that
happened then when and then suppose you
just like to turn it off then somebody
can go online or find another way to
find the device that can then control
the stimulation this is a real issue
yeah I was just gonna add actually on
that point that there are both security
and privacy concerns so there's the
security concern you just raised about
who has access and then picking up on
this sort of recognition that this is a
space where they're startup companies
not all of whom will make it it's
unclear what happens to that data that
brain data that then gets bought up by
somebody else I mean it's um it's really
fascinating in interrelated set of
questions and so we have a another
question for you dr. grant and dr. fine
singer who should set the ethical limits
to altruism and how fix should this be
by our looks to each other I think the
answer is we don't know and that's part
of the work that needs to be done we you
know there have been worked at in other
fields that are not neuroscience and the
example we often think about our living
organ donors
which is a very altruistic thing to do
you're basically giving of yourself and
that is an invasive surgery there's you
know there's potentially
life-threatening surgery although is
still a safe surgery otherwise we
wouldn't do it and so I think the jury
is still out I think it depends on the
potential benefits that you we as a
society judge may come from allowing
people to exercise their I guess their
right to altruism but all that actually
talk a little further about yeah i mean
i think that's right i mean i think you
know philosophers we might have a bit of
a biased opinion that we should be
heavily involved in this discussion but
in the space of you know limits ethical
limits to altruism
in a particular type of research i mean
it would be reasonable to expect that
that limit could shift around depending
on the wrist and the benefits of that
research and it would also be reasonable
to expect that the limit would be
context dependent not on the least not
just on the research but on the
participant right so this is a fairly
complex set of issues i don't know that
we have to settle on you know where the
limit is at this point but i do think
that we need to be very mindful of this
idea that there is reasonably a limit
and we haven't really paid enough
attention to the fact that there could
be very ethically concerning altruistic
sacrifices and that that is maybe where
we should start at the conversation so i
don't have a straight answer as to what
the limit should be but i do think it
should be in a interdisciplinary
discussion and we should learn from
clinicians patients themselves as well i
think we can all learn a lot from their
narratives on what it's like to give
back in some of this research and on
emphasis as well but i will say right
now the limits of altruism are
determined by each institutions
individual IRP who determined whether or
not something is okay to be done or a
study can be conducted and that's where
there's a lot of variability as
those who have started to look at these
issues have noticed that you can have
the same exact study reviewed by two IR
bees and get completely different
responses some IRA bees will say we will
let anything go as long as there is in
for consent you inform someone of all
the risks and if they still want to do
it then that's their choice and that
might be too extreme of you and there's
other places that say it doesn't matter
you know altruism if there's no
potential for direct benefit then the
study should never be conducted and
that's probably an extreme view so
there's somewhere in the middle and it's
gonna be variable depending on this
thing there's a question about the IRB
what happens when an army doesn't
understand the reasonable risk benefit
ratio or just the risk that a patient is
willing to accept and kind of assist
people due to the equation to reason or
influence the board member so I think
yes and that in fact I'll give a case
example that a statistic that's exactly
what happens in our situation where one
of the institutions that's part of the
multi institutional study pulled in
their emphasis because they had issues
with a non therapeutic trial concerns
about therapeutic misconception and they
did two things one is they consulted
with an emphasis that their institution
in terms of the validity or the
allowability of the study but they also
introduced something which I'm not sure
is the right answer either but they
they've introduced an emphasis into the
consent process to actively screen
patients to verify that they are
enrolling for the right reasons and they
understand the purpose of the study but
then the big question becomes what are
the tools that the Ephesus has to
evaluate those or anyone has to evaluate
those and there is the space that a lot
of work still needs to be done yeah and
I would just I mean I agree with that
answer completely this is a fairly
common question that comes up so I've
seen many of my colleagues be pulled in
to talk with IRB boards about you know
the amount of money right
that they're going to give to compensate
and they're bring concerns about that so
this is a common thing and I think it's
a good thing and then I would just sound
like a broken record but I would just
say that probably the best solution is
to bring in an ethicist that can work
interdisciplinarily with the clinician
as well to do this problem the brain
initiative you know it's on this base
new rewards we actually are asking the
projects to come in with a common IRB
even when the surgical sites and the
where the patients are being recruited
might be a different site so and so in
this case in that case then we will have
a single IRB that would apply to
everything that went out on that was
funded by that award that won't
necessarily get rid of all of the
problems or issues and certainly an IRB
could also change its its decision you
know MIT Award or myth myth trial but it
would help to get rid of the issue or to
at least address the issue of competing
standards and competing demands from
different institutions for an award that
is made that and then what would happen
if a patient originally agreed to take
on the risk and then later suffered some
risk so I mean I think it goes back to
what we just what we just heard and it
has a lot to do with consent and the
magical mystical challenge of trying to
properly understand and articulate the
risk and the benefits and that's really
difficult to do when you're dealing with
the organ of the brain in new
experimental studies it's hard enough to
do in areas that we already know but I I
mean I also sound like a pro printer but
it it really depends and probably it
would be I think you'd look a lot at the
procedural steps that were taken or not
taken
it did due diligence in the case of
cynical trials without the potential for
therapeutic benefits such as those
projects participating in the brain
research in human consortium the concept
of altruism as a motivating factor
becomes exponentially more important as
there is clearly no intended direct
therapeutic benefit to the individual or
society so is the altruism a form of
concentrating egoism above the real role
that motivates patients so I think I
might be misunderstanding this question
so I'm doctor Pradhan can chime in but
if the question is asking something like
is you know altruism really always a
form of self-interest or a form of
gaining something back for the ego
yourself if that's what it's asking that
may not necessarily be the case it's a
that's a good question is a fairly
robust philosophical question right so
we have these arguments in philosophy
about whether altruism is truly possible
right this idea that you're really
always doing something only to benefit
others right and so we were just
chatting before dr. prati and saying
look even when people do things
altruistic aliy they often feel good
about it right so is it is that really
the thing that's motivating them and I
would say that that's possible but it's
also possible that although some people
feel good as the result of doing
something altruistic aliy that doesn't
necessarily mean that they're doing it
so that they feel good right so it might
not actually rise to the level of being
the motivator and so it is possible to
have geralt rhythm where you're really
motivated to help other people but
subsequently get a benefit so I would I
would ask the person asking this
question to try to think through those
distinctions to see if we can really
find a space for altruism the question
is or statement I really like that
contributing altruistically actually can
increase your quality of life
this can see
to improve medical response or state of
health have there been have there been
any Studies on this I not in this space
not in the neuroscientific space and I
have to admit I don't know enough again
I'm going to call on the transplant
space but I imagine there has been a
pretty significant work in again living
donors in terms of what they experience
and why they do it and their motivation
to do so but I will say from personal
experience having worked in a couple
different trials especially in the
neuroscientific space there's a unique
component to the altruism which is that
most of the people that are
participating these studies have some
kind of chronic neurological disease
some kind of disability associated with
it
and as a result they've lost some
quality of life they've lost some kind
of interaction with society and the way
that they knew before their disease and
participation especially in more chronic
studies offers them a purpose that
offers them a way to integrate back into
society which I think ends up being a
very significant benefit or I should say
because we haven't proven it it's
potentially a very significant benefit
in terms of their psychological state
and their overall mental health so I
think if we dig into it there is
significant potential for improvements
in quality in life and sense of self and
well-being let actually comment on that
yeah I mean this is an interesting
question and it's very possible that
that's the case it's also possible that
we could find other kind of correlations
between you know someone's ability to
satisfy or pursue the things that they
care about and their blood pressure
right so having less stress having lower
blood pressure having better cardiac
health like who knows what the
correlations might be between altruism
and some of these things and not I don't
know of any studies that have done that
specifically with altruism it would be
interesting and I would just add that
even if we even in the absence of those
correlations we still might have a bear
good reason to consider improvements in
quality of life as being something we
care about promoting in the research
lawmakers to Xperia P ad to include
those with treatment-resistant
psychiatric diseases if at all so I'll
use as an example dementia us say
Alzheimer's there has been a move at a
discussion emerging about expanding
opportunities for physician assisted
suicide to populations that don't fit
the traditional criteria so those
criteria in the states that the five
states where it's available in the
United States you have to have a
terminal illness see about six months or
less to live there are these other
safeguards like mandatory waiting
periods and crucially you have to be
mentally competent to be able to have
the law recognize your decision so as we
move more downstream that is more than
six months away from that terminal
ending point it raises a really
challenging set of ethical questions
that are they're very ripe right now you
know and I'll just without taking a view
on which is right on just lay out one of
the big debates which is how much
autonomy does someone have as in with
the neurodegenerative disease their
brain is changing ways that we think may
affect their competence the capacity to
make this really important decision at
the same time what's happening is that
they're experiencing and I think this
gets to the question the pain and the
challenge of that disorder in that
degeneration in new ways and in ways
that might make them and their family
thing that physician assisted suicide is
an appropriate indeed a humane and
ethical response so I just think it's a
it's a really great question it's really
challenging and I hope that we'd have an
informed discussion around it in the
years to come because it
is coming it's already criteria yeah so
I think I'm going to interpret that
question a little bit more broadly and I
do think that conceptual and empirical
work in the space of ethics can help
elucidate what the main questions are
and how different stakeholders think
about them and that kind of turn help
policymakers answer complicated
questions like these and dr. pearl
Taylor dr. Fonseca this yeah I mean I
think I think yeah good question I think
that it's possible that some of the
stuff we are learning about the brain
through advances in neuroscience could
help us kind of understand different
levels of cognitive capacity so if we
had if we had patients where we were not
sure how much capacity they had with
respect to being able to consent or make
decisions about end-of-life or a
physician assisted suicide I imagine
that there may be a space to come in and
maybe use I don't know use some of those
techniques to help confirm that indeed
the patient does have enough capacity to
do this but I would be very careful
about that
and I would say there's a lot of
philosophical and ethical work that
needs to be done before trying to use
any of that technology in that space I
think there really a very interesting
one that question is that it asks about
expending the criteria for physician
assisted treatment resistant psychiatric
diseases
I will add one aspect which is perhaps
overly optimistic but we need some
optimism here is that you know we are
living in an era that we are starting to
understand psychiatric disease
completely different lights where we
understand it and I often say just like
any other neurological disease that can
affect the brain and result in
neurological impairment you know in
Neurology we think about people that
have symptoms that we can actually
physically assess and do a physical exam
on in my opinion and I think in many
people's view psychiatric disease is not
that different except that the dimension
space is in the cognitive and
interactive psychiatric space those
types of assessments so I think we need
to be careful about losing hope
especially in an era where we are
investing tremendously in developing
therapies for these very people who have
treatment resistant psychiatric diseases
so I think that needs to factor into the
equation as well if I can just add one
last wrinkle on that we have to be
really have to have a very challenging
discussion about limiting conditions so
take Down syndrome I'm Iceland is almost
eliminating the reproduction of Down
syndrome by parental screening and
selective abortion for some this is a
miracle and awesome for others this is
horrible
but the question leads to those sorts of
potential policy implications because if
you can figure out at 35 that you have
this neuropsychiatric disorder you might
be able to figure out even earlier and
at what point do you evaluate risk and
benefits who gets to make those
decisions um just this really
challenging ethical Tarina I agree with
everyone here that there's really
opportunity for philosophy for at the
current Pyrrhic aware conceptual work
and I again I hope we do it well thank
you everybody for your time and for
these wonderful answers and thank you to
our audience for those software working
questions I would like to ask you to
continue submitting your questions to
our speakers as they can follow up via
email so thank you again to our speakers
and coming up next our innovative
neurotechnologies tract is about
to begin where our speakers will explore
the most cutting-edge innovations that
will foster the advanced understanding
of the human brain by supporting the
development and application of such
technologies hope to see you there